[music playing]
OK, you're good, Cara.
You know the bit I said about
gravity doing the first bit?
Yeah.
That's wrong.
You're just going to have to
muscle it out most of the way.
Oh, no.
Hopefully, I'll get across
before I get scared.
That's what I'm hoping for.
So speed is my key, which
probably isn't very clever.
But whatever.
[grunting]
I'll tell you what, this is
going to be a workout for her.
Oh, my god.
Oh, god, I'm scared.
[grunting] Oh, no.
[grunting] Oh, [bleep].
This is going to be so long.
There's so much
friction with the rope
and the carabiner over
it that each couple
of feet is like a pull-up.
[bleep]
Oh.
So she's about a
quarter of the way
and already she's
grinding to a halt.
[grunting]
Come on, Cara, you can do this.
Push that device as
far forward as you can.
There you go.
You need both hands.
[grunting]
Great job.
Keep pushing.
[grunting]
You can do it.
Guys, phhh!
[grunting] Oh, god.
Come on.
Go, girl.
You're doing so well.
Just inch it out, muscle it out.
[grunting]
So close.
Keep coming.
OK.
Come on, you bastard.
[grunting]
Another 5 foot
and you're there.
I'm so close.
[grunting]
[inaudible].
Come on here.
[grunting]
Here we go.
[grunting] Ugh!
Ooh!
Oh.
Oh, my god.
That was really hard.
Sweat.
Speed is usually my go-to.
It was a bad idea, because
after I got halfway,
it just tore me up--
my core, my arms.
Yeah, that last bit
was really hardcore.
My stomach is shaking.
[laughs] It's good.
It's good.
Never give up.
[inaudible]
So that was definitely
harder work than I anticipated.
But our Cara muscled it out.
She's got great natural
physicality of strength,
and most importantly, kind
of that never give up spirit.
And out here, that is king.